meanwhile Sky News understands more than
270 people have been made redundant
after the British Airline flybe cease
trading with all flights now canceled
the company operated scheduled services
from Belfast Birmingham and Heathrow
including flights to Amsterdam and
Geneva
and Sky News understands the 277 of
flybe's Staff have been made redundant
the airline had 530 flights running per
week after returning to operations in
April of 2022 now those flights were
across 23 routes serving airports in the
UK including Belfast City Birmingham
East Midlands and Leeds Bradford now
Sky's business correspondent Paul Kelso
has all the latest on this from
Birmingham Airport well flyby we should
say is a much smaller business than when
it went into Administration last in
March 2020 on the eve of the pandemic
reaching the UK it was an employer with
two and a half thousand staff crucial to
Regional connectivity in the UK it went
bust it failed it was bought out of
administration in a much much smaller
Airline began operating under the same
brand in April last year you can see one
of the planes on the tarmac here at
Birmingham they're not flying anymore
all flights canceled with immediate
effect of no prospected and getting back
in the air
277 staff made redundant as you said two
and a half thousand passengers were
expected to travel today they're not
going anywhere and around 75
000 people had forward bookings I
understand there'll be no refunds from
the airline itself it's run out of money
that's why the planes are on the ground
they'll people have to go to credit card
and debit card operators or tour
operators to try and get a refund
there's about 300 people the
administrators estimate have been
displaced that is they've taken one leg
and they have a return book and they
can't take today the civil aviation
Authority are working with the
administrators and CAA will they say get
those people home uh comfortably uh
around 300 staff in this much smaller
business it was bought by a U.S hedge
fund Cyrus Capital effectively the brand
and leases to some of these aircraft
these players are all leased they're not
owned out right the Cyrus capital of the
that's like around 50 million pounds
trying to keep the business in the air
but ultimately a regional a regional an
airline based on Regional connectivity
and this is a really big route the
important route between Belfast and the
mainland UK around 100 of these staff
who've made redundant work in Belfast so
this is a really big deal and the
administrator told me a little earlier
what his plans are the impact will be
what his plans are to try and find a
buyer
at a time when we're talking about
travel infrastructure and leveling up
this is a really unhelpful thing to
happen and just shows the importance of
having well-invested infrastructure to
do this
um feel you know it's really unfortunate
this happens to to the Belfast the main
Belfast London connection and Belfast
Birmingham and there are other there are
other airlines who can pick up the slack
but but our our hope is that somebody
sees that and approaches us you know for
you know to revive the airline
so there's clearly an impact on
traveling passengers a great deal of
inconvenience and possibly at worst
we've heard of people who are coming
over to see the musical Hamilton uh this
weekend those plans uh have bit in the
dust and so there's clearly an impact
there's an impact obviously on staff
who's been made redundant should say the
January payroll was moved yesterday so
flyby stuff did get paid yesterday small
Comfort but at least that did happen but
this is a much smaller concern it isn't
as big a impact on the UK's travel
infrastructure as it was the last time
it went bus but nevertheless it still
raises this question in a country where
the trains are not working as well as we
would like Regional Airline operator
like this the core of the business does
not appear to be profitable
Paul Kelso there for us if you have been
affected by the collapse of flybe uh
please do get in touch with us here at
Sky News and tell us Your Story by
emailing in to news at skynews.com or
indeed you can send us a message on
WhatsApp on 07583 Triple zero eight five
three